-OK, I'm in.
-Good.
Now I just have to
pick the guy.
You? No, no, no, no.
See, that's the fun part.
Just so you don't make it
too easy on yourself,
we'll pick the loser.
Cameron, right?
Yeah. Can I help you
with something?
I'm Padgett.
We were in Señora Parker's
Spanish class together,
remember?
Yeah, guess so.
Hola!
Hi.
Good times.
Wait, where are you going?
I thought you were finished.
Cameron!
What a weird coincidence.
Well,
I'm here every morning,
so I'm pretty sure
the only weird part is you.
Fair enough.
There's just so much of it.
What do horses eat anyway?
Well, that one, Jimbo over there,
he likes Chipotle.
Gilly prefers sushi.
Seriously, more?
I'm just capturing
the moment.
You can't enjoy this without
sharing it
with like 500 strangers?
Five hundred? Try 887,132.
And they're not strangers.
-They're followers.
-Followers?
You mean like a cult?
Disgusting!
Sorry!
I'm sorry for laughing.
It's just I've never seen
such an uncoordinated
dismount.
Aren't you captain
of the dance team?
What?
It's mostly grass, right?
You make me
Feel like I'm livin'
A teenage dream
All right, Kweller.
I can't sleep
Let's run away
And don't ever look back
Don't ever look…
-That's the bet guy.
-Yeah.
Who is this guy?
When you look at me
Just one touch
Now, baby, I believe
This is real
So take a chance
And don't ever…
They're actually
kind of good.
Wait,
are you actually smiling?
-What?
-I don't know.
I've just never
seen you like this.
High school is just
a bunch of scared people
pretending to be
something they're not.
We got our clothes
and we're done now, right?
Oh God, what now?
You've done this before?
Literally
thousands of times.
Really?
You've shaved a guy's face?
Sorry! Can't hear you!
Wow! You are good.
How do you feel?
Like I just lost
Dancing with the Stars.
Well,
if I didn't know any better
and you weren't my brother,
I'd say you look pretty hot.
Right, Padgett?
Yeah, sure.
You know you could totally
make money at this, right?
You know
I don't care about money.
Or not, but…
keeping your talent
locked away,
what are you hiding from?
You know, I could ask you
the same question.
What are you talking about?
Well, I'm talking about…
this.
And…
And these.
Not the eyelashes,
they're glued on
pretty tight.
I know this isn't usually
my style, obviously.
But… what do you think?
-I think yes!
-Sorry…
I hate to interrupt
this adorable moment,
but, Padgett,
isn't there something
you should tell Cameron?
-Alden, what are you doing?
-Leave her alone, Alden.
-Shut up, Quinn.
-What's going on?
I made a bet with Alden
that I could take
some person and, and…
-and make them over.
-Some person?
What kind of person?
Can we please just talk
about this in private?
What kind of person,
Padgett?
The biggest loser
we could find,
so she could turn
him into prom king.
-But that was before--
-Wait! So I was a bet?
-No--
-No, I was a fucking bet!
You can all go to hell.
Someone special once told me
high school is just
a bunch of scared people
pretending to be
something they're not.
But it doesn't have
to be that way.
That's the lesson
he taught me.
I only wish I didn't have
to lose him to learn it.
Whoa.
Hey.
I meant what I said.
I'm gonna start being honest
about who I am.
From now on, I swear.
OK, well,
if we're being honest.
There was one thing in your
speech that you got wrong.
What was it?
You never really lost me.
Seriously?
-I'm done with her.
-Thank you.
Now, where were we?
Yes! Woo-hoo! Finally!